New health revelations coming to light
about Democratic Senator Dianne Feinstein.
Her office confirming to our Manu Raju
that the senator suffered complications
from her long bout with shingles.
Complications including encephalitis,
which is an inflammation of the brain.
Senator Feinstein this afternoon
first denied having encephalitis and said
it was just the flu.
But her office then confirmed
that she did indeed have encephalitis.
This is the 89 year old senator facing
is facing increasing questions
about her mental fitness and ability
to serve as a senator.
Senator, thanks to you both.
Senator Feinstein, do you still feel
like you're sick to some extent right now?
I you but you have to resign.
Yes, you guys
women are in this sloganeering.
But working for her office now
Thank you.
I mean, it's painful to watch that.
Manu Raju is OUTFRONT. Marty,
what more are you learning tonight?
There has not been much information
coming from Senator Feinstein
or her office in the aftermath of her
contracting shingles back in February.
She was gone for several months.
She returned there and she has said very
little about everything that happened.
But then the revelation that she did get
in some flights in addition to the Ramsay
Hunt, syndrome, two complications
that came from the result of shingles.
She initially denied that, said
that she was in case of the bad, bad flu.
And then she let her office later
confirm that indeed
she had broader health complications.
Then talking to senators
when asked about whether or not
they believe she is fit to serve.
They sidestepped the question
Do you have confidence that
she can continue to do this rigorous job?
We're all human
and we all have health issues.
And right now she is performing
as a United States senator, doing her job.
Are you worried about her abilities
to do her job?
Well, I can't answer that.
Well, let me because I don't know why
I have confidence in her judgment
and her her family and her staff's
judgment
Now, questions
about Senator Feinstein
have persisted for several years.
She was slated to become the first woman
to chair the Senate Judiciary Committee.
She essentially was pushed aside
by top Democrats
who were concerned
about her ability to do that.
And she could have been the first female
to be the president pro tem of the Senate,
meaning the most senior member
of the Senate, someone who's in line
in the presidential succession.
She did not take that position.
That allowed Patty Murray to become
the president pro tem instead All
because of these health issues that came
even before this recent bout of shingles.
All right, Mary,
what about the question
that we heard there in that exchange
where someone asked MS.
Pelosi
if she was working for Feinstein's office,
which was referring to the woman
that has been by a Feinstein side
all the time, it seems recently
Nancy Pelosi's eldest daughter
also seemed Also named Nancy, I should say
Nancy Careen, proud to is her name.
She has been by Feinstein side
since returning to the Senate.
What do you know about their relationship
Manu?
Yes, there have been.
It was an interesting development
learning about this in recent days.
She is someone the Pelosis
and the Feinstein have been very close
over the years of coming through
San Francisco politics.
Their office says this is a personal
relationship, not a political one.
And this is why
the former speaker's daughter, eldest
daughter,
is working with her, essentially working
as a caretaker of sorts.
But it has also raised
some political questions as well.
Nancy Pelosi is supporting Adam Schiff
to be the next senator from California
to replace Dianne Feinstein.
If Feinstein were to resign,
then Gavin Newsom, the governor, has said
that he would appoint
a black woman to the post.
If he were to do that, perhaps that could
make it shake up the Senate race there,
maybe make makeshift bid for
the Senate seat Senate more difficult now.
Pelosi's office denies that's the case,
but those are
the questions that are swirling around
Dianne Feinstein and it'll future.
Certainly. All right.
And adds a fascinating wrinkle to it.
Manu, thank you.
I want to go now to our chief
medical correspondent, Dr.
Sanjay Gupta.
I mean, Dr. Gupta, let's just be honest.
This is something that really
has captivated the country.
People want to understand
what's going on here.
And obviously, you're a neurosurgeon.
Let's just start
with this latest news on encephalitis.
Which they said, you know, she didn't have
and then said, in fact, she had.
How serious could encephalitis be
and what does it do to a brain?
Well, it can be very serious.
I mean, it's it's inflammation
of the brain, the whole brain.
I mean, people often
have heard the term meningitis.
And I'll just show you here quickly, Erin.
Meningitis is an inflammation of the outer
layers of the brain with encephalitis.
You're talking about the brain itself.
And it can be a challenging diagnosis
that will tell you to make.
They they had suspicion probably
because of her shingles initially.
And then she probably had symptoms,
which can be a little bit vague
in the beginning.
But things like fever,
it could be neck ache,
sensitivity to light,
but then it can go into mental confusion
and seizures and it can be, again,
a challenging diagnosis.
You get MRI scans,
you may even have to do a lumbar puncture
to find out, but it can be serious.
If it's not treated,
it can resolve as well.
And a lot of the sort of more acute
symptoms if you will,
fever and pain and things
like that, headache, they can go away.
But you could be left with with mental
confusion, difficulties with memory.
And she's 89 years old.
So, you know, all of that is amplified
in someone who is that old as well, Erin.
No, certainly.
And as you say, those things are not
the ones that necessarily go away.
So these are
these are serious considerations.
So now the senator's office is saying
while her encephalitis has resolved
and obviously due
to what you just said, we don't know
exactly what that means fully.
But they also say she continues
to have complications from something
called Ramsay Hunt Syndrome.
What is Ramsay Hunt Syndrome?
Yeah, well,
this is another sort of consequence
that that rare one
but a consequence of shingles sometimes.
So both encephalitis and Ramsay Hunt
could be a result of her initial shingles.
What this is
and you may have heard of seeing
a lot of people have heard of shingles.
Basically,
if you've had chicken pox as a kid,
the virus that causes
chickenpox may not go away.
It stays inside your body.
And then at some point, as adults,
it gets reactivated.
We don't really know why.
And this case,
it could have been reactivated
for all sorts of different reasons,
but it affects that nerve.
We just showed it.
There on the screen for a second.
It's the facial nerve.
That's the yellow sort of lines
you see on someone's face there.
It can affect all those nerves, people's
faces, may essentially become paralyzed
as a result of that.
They may develop lesions even in their
ear, along their face, in their eye.
She was complaining about her eyes.
The lesions could be inside the mouth.
It can be really painful.
People who've had shingles will oftentimes
describe the pain
that they have with that.
Imagine that, Aaron, on your face.
Now, it can also resolve,
but it can take a while.
How quickly was it diagnosed?
Did she get antivirals
where she given steroids?
Those are the types of things
that can actually make it go away.
Quicker.
People often compare it to Bell's Palsy,
which is similar.
But Ramsey Hunt is often more serious
and is less likely to resolve completely
Well, these things are it's
very important to understand it
and of course, incredibly serious
and and frightening, I'm sure.
All right. Thank you very much, Sanjay.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, this is coming as Senator
Feinstein is facing growing calls
from fellow Democrats to step down.
So what do the voters in California think?
Kyung Lah is OUTFRONT in San Francisco,
which is Feinstein's hometown
I was mayor of San Francisco
for nine years.
Senator Dianne Feinstein
conducting normal business didn't
change concerns at home about her health.
And anything we can do to help,
I think we should.
After these images earlier
this week that stunned
San Francisco native Tom Benton
just sadness.
I think first and foremost, shock
to some degree at
at how frail she seems.
Benton of progressive group
Indivisible helped organize
this open letter to Senator Feinstein,
signed by activists
across California asking her to
resign to focus on her health
Then had voted for Feinstein for decades.
He'd witnessed her ascent
from the first female mayor of San
Francisco to the first woman
California sent to the U.S.
Senate.
A trailblazer
who Benton says needs to pass the torch.
Why would anybody wish that on a man
or a woman?
Why would anybody feel that it's their
right to be in that kind of distress?
That's the kind of dignified
end to a career that you would want.
I don't understand that aging and ending
a career are often private decisions,
but in public service,
that's not always a choice.
I'm announcing that I will not be
a candidate for reelection to Congress
in 20, 22.
It's time for me to come home.
That's former California Congresswoman
Jackie Speier, who retired in 20, 22.
She believes Feinstein is facing
an unfair amount of scrutiny.
I think there is a fair amount of misogyny
in this case.
I think that there is this willingness
to look at women
and judge them differently.
I think it's a personal decision
to resign.
She's already made the personal decision
to retire.
Is it a personal decision
if taxpayers are paying for your job, if
she's doing her job?
I don't think there's a question here.
Speer chose to retire
not due to age or health,
but she says to spend time with her
husband.
Speer has said one way
to fix a problem in
Washington is a mandatory retirement age.
But until that happens,
Speer says of her former colleague,
that should be Feinstein. Lynn's choice.
Having said that,
you think there should be an age limit.
Should that apply in this case?
I said that there is a time for all of us
when we are
level of acuity is not as it once was.
That's an evaluation
that each member makes
Well, having spoken to a lot of people
who either know Dianne Feinstein,
who've worked for her in the city
or who are represented by her,
they say that this is about more than age.
This is actually about more than Dianne
Feinstein legacy.
And this is a city
that is admired her and really,
truly cares about that legacy, Erin.
They are really concerned
about the business of the Senate
and the representation
of this state of 39 million people Erin.
All right, Kyung, thank you.
Let's think about interesting
Jackie's arguments there.